The Joe Rogan experience. Boom. And we're
live. What's up brother? How are Ya man,
Joe Rogan. I am so happy to be
here. I'm so happy to see you.
Fuck, you've gone through
a journey. Oh Man.
Since the last time I see it is tea.
Yesterday was one year from your
heart transplant anniversary. Exactly.
Wow. One year. And Joe,
if I told you it was easy,
I'd be lying.
But man,
it was so worth the journey
and they ain't even funny.
What does it feel like right now?
Like having another person's heart in
your body? What does that feel like? Well,
a lot of times it feels like I actually
did die and this is just the dream,
you know, mind right now. Yep.
Wow. This, this is a, I pick this,
this would be my heaven. You look
great. You're still jacked. No,
not losing any weight. Oh yeah.
Yeah. But I mean, you still,
you're still jacked. He's still
got muscles. Uh, you know,
it's a fall from where I was.
I really appreciate that though.
But I, I, you know, I look at
myself, man, it's just, uh, you know,
fragmented. What I used to be,
but you know, I'm still here.
That's what's so important to me, man.
Well, the ridiculous thing you were doing,
you're making videos of your working out
like getting ready and after your heart
attack,
heart operation,
this you have a heart transplant and
you're running in a parking lot and you
trip and fall. I'm like Jesus
man, slow down. Like yeah,
cause you have it there.
They just decided that you were just
going to start pushing from the beginning.
Well, uh, actually, uh,
my brain was ready but my body wasn't.
They warn you about doing that. Did
they say it was okay? They told me that,
you know, they gave me three city
walk and you know, me, I'm like,
I walk shit, I can run
it. At least my mindset,
I could. Right. What
does it feel like though?
Like when you like what is the difference
between the way your heart feels now?
It's night and day.
You know,
before I got the transplant
it had got really bad,
really bad. I had a flat line
two more times, uh, you know,
before the actual transplant. And it was,
I couldn't go through one another frat.
Right. And that would've been it. But
the difference now, I mean it feels,
I only say flatline. Like
your heart stops. Yes. Yes.
And what did they do to start
it back up again? Okay. Um,
after I had this last heart attack,
um, they asked me to see miss firstly,
do you want to us to put in a pacemaker?
And I thought about it a lot because
my brother and my older brother walked,
had a pacemaker installed before he
passed away and his pacemaker was actually
going off, uh, when he, when
he died. So I'm like, man,
I didn't really do any good for him.
So I was like going back and forth and
then all this, uh, something voice,
say the equity and get it. And so I told
me I put it in and pacemakers saved me.
Wow. So it went flat, like see
your heart gave up and then the p,
what is the pacemaker do exactly?
It's like a defibrillator,
you know, like raped.
They had the paddles that give you
an electric shock, you know, that's,
that's what the pacemaker does is just
give you a little joy on the inside,
you know, inside and it's connected
directly to your heart wound,
that sucker flat lines. It
gives you a jolt. Wow. Yeah.
Did you feel it? No. No. I was,
I was dead until we say, well,
you did, you don't feel nothing.
So you had blocked out to,
uh,
it's not a blackout or a,
like those off when you're sleeping.
Death is totally different.
Totally different. And you,
I knew that I was dead
before I died before at flat.
Right.
It was just being my wife at home and I
was talking to her just like I'm talking
to you. And the next thing,
all the lights went out.
It was like a one of
those old fashioned TVs.
I don't know if you're old enough to
remember these black and white TVs. Yeah.
Yeah. That's exactly how
it was. They're just tiny,
tiny pinprick of light and you know that,
that's it.
Wow. It's no, you know, you
absolutely know that this is it.
And it's not,
you know,
this is the irreversible
and you know that it's,
this is death and not just, you're
not just those at all. You know,
did you have a near death experience?
I everything.
Um,
the only thing you have to,
only thing I had time to say was
I had time to call my wife's name,
but I mean, when they say things rush,
you know, everything was like, this is it,
this is it. You know, you're not
going to be able to do this anymore.
You're not going to get this is it,
this is the final finalization
of everything hits you.
Like, no, this is, you know,
this is the final thing.
This is your last moment on earth
and you know it. And I'm like,
what do you do? How I could do was say my
wife's name. And that was, that was it.
So the pacemaker kicks in and
then you wrote back online.
Yeah. And it was, so that's a damn good
description. And then it was like a,
I thought I felt like that
I had been asleep for hours.
It was the best,
most peaceful,
restful time of my entire life.
Wow.
In just a short moment,
if felt like I had been asleep for eight
hours, so rested so well rested, so,
and my wife told me,
he goes just a short period of time,
but it felt like I had been asleep for
eight hours. So this happened twice? Yes.
The second time was in the hospital.
Oh Wow.
So they tell you, okay, Mr.
Fletcher, we have a heart for you.
Yeah, they call me like two 40
in the morning, I think it was.
So you have to get in there right
now. Is that how no one, no,
I had hours before I had to
actually be at the hospital.
I said be be at the hospital thing
like six or seven. Yeah. Yeah.
And then you think in a wall boy.
Uh,
I was happy and sad when I got the call.
I was happy for myself,
um,
because I didn't think I could
go through another flat line,
but I was sad for the donor and spam.
Yeah.
I knew somebody had to pass away in
order for me to get that heart. Yeah.
So I felt real bad about that.
So they put it in you,
you wake up,
what does that feel like?
Um,
it felt like, uh, um, being born again,
a rebirth.
I never try and let it go at life.
Wow. Yup. I get it. Another
start. Another chance. They, it,
my son Ain't over.
Wow.
So from the moment this,
so they have to open you up right here.
They do that chest spreader thing and uh,
and what is all that like?
Well, are you, of course that
you were out, but when you
wake up and you look down,
you're covered with stitches,
right? I mean, it must be
a giant scar, right? It's,
they are so good now.
Don't get it. You know,
I have a scar, but considering they do
this my second time being split open,
you know, first time, uh,
and Oh five when they put
a metal valve in a Frat,
when I, during that operates a three times
on, you know, on the table during the,
the operation itself. Uh, so, um,
me and flat line or a five flat lines,
I think I'm at my limit, man. Wow.
Um, I seen the scars. They had to
take the pace, the pace maker out.
They took the metal bat out of
the well make, take the old heart,
had the middle path ministry,
took the whole heart out a put
in a new heart and a is this man,
it's a unbelievably,
this before shower would
kill me if I took a shower.
I be doing for the rest
of the day a shower. Yeah.
Or shall we kill me for the rest of the
day when I had a seat in the shower,
you know, uh, how would, how
would a shower kill you? Oh Man.
It was bad amount of physical activity
and you know, uh, how, you know,
you people take taking
a shower for granted,
but that amount of physical
activity would kill me.
I'd be wiped out just for washing your
sheets. Yes. For the rest of the day,
man. It was so you were hanging by
smell? Yeah, definitely death. Wow.
It was, you know, kill me, you know,
and my wife was opening jars. Me,
here I am former
world champion and I got my wife,
hey baby.
Because he opened his jelly jar for me.
Wow. Yeah. It's a humbling, humbling.
Very big time. Big Time. How long did
you have to stay in the hospital for? Um,
we went in the hospital, not
very long. I mean we got out of,
uh,
we went straight there in intensive care.
They keep you there for like three days,
but I think I was probably
released to within two weeks total.
Wow. And then are you using a
walker? Are you walking fine?
Like I wouldn't say I was walking fine,
but I was walking just
walking slowly. Oh, big time.
Big Time. Slowly. Yeah, I
was crawling along. Wow.
And how long did it take for you to get
to where you're at? Like now? Like now,
I'd have no idea that you had a heart
transplant really. Well, I appreciate it.
You know, when I saw you mean you
look very happy. Oh, I am happy.
You look like you're glowing.
I am extremely happy.
Just to be alive when you
come that close to dying.
I mean every day is just a blessing,
man.
If people actually hate doing
CT, I'm blessed man. I'm
sorry I got no complaints.
Blessed. Oh yes, no
complaints whatsoever man.
I seen I wanted to hug them.
Joe,
I'm so happy to see you man.
I'm alive.
Wow. Cause we, you know, last
time we talked about, um,
me meeting the transplant and I needed
the transplant it, now I'm back. I had it,
the first six months were rough
the first six months after
the jelly jar. Oatmealy tell you
jog, just not being able to do,
you know, normal things. The first
thing I tried to do was walk.
So they had me walk around,
I guess a city block,
maybe city Black Joe.
When I first tried to walk around a city
block, I'd have to stop probably 12,
13 times and take a seat
and get up and try to walk.
And it was, it was killing
me, man. My, my, you know, my,
my wife was slowed down. He slowed
down and walk with me and us too.
It was such a struggle and I'm like,
you know what,
I don't give a damn how long it take me.
I'm going to make you mad and I'm
going to make you keep, keep going.
And what kind of activity are
you able to do now? A year later,
I am a lifting again, but very
lightly I'm able to do, you know,
the machines and stuff in the 10.
Uh,
I think I've been able to do
that for the last two months.
So when you say that lightly, is
this by doctor's orders? Oh yeah.
I can't do anything without
them approving it first. Yeah.
I except they run into the parking
lot. I didn't even approved. Yeah.
My mind was like, Oh yeah, you can do it.
My body was like leaving me
out this month. Yeah. So what,
what holds you back in terms
of like lifting weights?
Like why do you have to go light?
And my strength is just nowhere near what
it used to be. The strength is still,
you know, I can tell, but, uh, you know,
I have a long way to go, but, you know,
just to be able to do anything.
So I guess I kinda need
to do and I do what I can.
And that's what I tell people all the
time, man, if you can't, uh, you know,
do what you want to do, at least get
in there and do what you can do. Yeah.
It's better than doing nothing.
Yeah.
So now did they have you on medication
to make sure that the heart doesn't get
rejected by your body?
Most definitely in an APP and people
out there who've had transplants,
I know that they were like, oh man. Yeah.
I take about 21 different medications.
Yep. 21 different Medicare and will
the side effects of the stuff? Um,
they used to be worse, but now, you know,
my feet are swollen pretty much every day.
Um, something in the medical
kind of kicks my arthritis.
I have arthritis too, so it kind of
kicks in and told are stiff, you know,
pretty much every day.
But when I compare the side effects
to the work took possibly happen,
which is deaf assigned fixing shit,
I'll take them now, will you have
to take this medication forever?
Uh, it gets less, less and
less. When I go back, uh,
this month back up to Palo Alto
where they did the transplant, um,
they're going to take off about
four or five different medications.
So I'm a year out now. They lasted
me. And the further you get out,
the less medication and thinking
eventually we'll get down to two or three,
but you'll always have to
take some oh yeah, definitely.
And it's just because your body doesn't
understand why it has someone's heart in
it. Um, for a while that,
that in the beginning,
like I'm taking 21 now,
it's because, you know, uh,
to keep the chances of rejection
down by the fact that you're checked,
they understand that hey, w it wasn't
the one that she was born with, right.
Answer, foreign, you
know, a foreign heart.
And I really want to talk to you about
that heart. What I know about it. Um,
it's a woman's heart, right?
Yeah. So, you know, you know,
I thought it was going to drop a
bomb on following. Yeah. Very good.
Yeah. But I tell you that,
that threw me for a loop. Yeah.
And I was,
you know,
I'm always talking about how strong
my faith is and you know, um,
faith, faith, faith, faith
man, superman of faith, uh,
and I could have so much faith
to Matt and phase me. You know,
I went into the operation, hey, I see
you guys on the other side of is because,
you know, I got, I know I'm going to be
our, I got so much faith that, you know,
I'm gonna get through this,
so I'm gonna see you guys.
But when the doctor came in and told me
that I had a woman's heart that sacked
the shit out of my face because I had
done steady, you know, I looked, you know,
stated on this,
the,
the survival rate of male to
female and it wasn't good.
The states I had read wasn't good.
When they do a female to me, I'm sorry,
female to Male, the tree is
not good. And I was like,
everything I had read said it's not a
good thing. The doctor comes in and says,
Yep, you've got a woman's heart. And she
wasn't that much younger than you are.
Fuck that.
That know sideman yeah, tested my
faith big time. How did she die?
I have no idea. I have no idea. But, um,
the thing I have feelings,
I haven't talked to the family.
I would love to.
I don't know anything about it,
but I had these feelings and I really
would like to know if what I'm feeling is
right. You know, I want, I really want
to meet the family and let you know,
let them know that I'm out here doing
everything I can to raise donor awareness.
And if their mother or their wife or
their sister or their aunt didn't die in
vain and then I'm doing my absolute best
to carry on and let people know that,
you know,
she was a donor and that it's so
utterly important for people to donate,
to get the gift of life.
What are these feelings that you have?
I have feelings that,
uh,
for some reason I can see that I feel
like she was the oriental lady and I,
I, you know, I don't know why,
but I really have feelings like that
and I feel like I can see this woman
telling her husband,
you know, I'll see it.
And we'd get home from work and making
plans with their kids for the weekend.
And I have no idea if
this is right or not,
but I just had those feelings.
Are they recurring? Yes.
And you like, do you remember
it like a memory? It's, um,
it's like I get to look into her,
you know,
her existence, her, her
life and I, you know,
I have no, I could be totally
wrong. She could be a Jamaican lady.
I have no idea. Or, uh, if
I'm in the ballpark or not,
I just had this feeling. I
just have a feeling. Wow.
Do you have any unusual cravings
or anything like either a,
I don't think, uh, no. I
don't think I have any.
I do talk to her and I feel like that,
uh, you know, when, when like when I
was walking around and I've told him,
tried to make it around that block,
I would often ask her for help
to help me make it around me.
Wow. Yeah. I talked to her
a lot. Wow. Come on lady.
I need your help. You have a name
for it? I just call him the lady.
Come on lady. I need you.
Wow. Wow, that's crazy.
You're superman from
Katherine has a lady's heart.
Now when you say that there's,
it's not,
the results aren't good for lady
hearts and male bodies. What'd you,
did you say that to the doctor?
Yeah, me and the doctor is so, um,
it's so funny.
I don't even know if the doctor's
suppose because it was this one doctor.
He would come in and young
guy and he would come in
every day. How are you doing,
Mr Footer? And I would say
I'm blessed. I don't care.
When I woke up from the transplant,
I consider every second after that
a blessing. It's borrowed time, man.
It wasn't supposed to be here.
So my answer's always,
I'm blessed so he can meet you. How are
you doing? I'm blessed him. But he said,
you know what, you're going to change.
They're not gonna know, doc. It's not.
And you could say going to
make me change my answer them,
I'm going to always be blessed
no matter what you say. He said,
you think you're doing really good, don't
you and I were here. Yeah. I think I'm,
I'm, I'm alive. Yeah.
I think I'm doing good.
I walked around this a hospital corridor.
I think I'm doing really good.
He said,
you're not,
you're doing about what you're supposed
to be doing and you have a woman's heart
and it's too small for you.
And she was almost your age.
I cannot fuck it's too small.
Yeah.
He told me that the heart
was too small and uh,
the lady was,
I was 58 or nine and 59 cause
I'd be 60 on June the eighth.
So, uh, he says it's too small and
you're not, you know, you're not
doing anything extraordinary.
You just do an average. And
she's eight. And I'm like, man,
fuck for the rest of the day.
I was fucked. I was fucking,
I'm like, man, I was, you know,
guy, why didn't you do this to me?
Why didn't you give me a woman?
Sorry. And O's warming it. Dad,
why can't you give me an age? Why? God,
I was questioning, why did you
do this to me? Did you ask him?
Heck, what do you mean the doctor
or guide the doctor? Uh, I didn't,
I need to ask the doctor that my
doctor did come in and I feel New York.
I'm sorry. I did ask the doctor.
I asked her, I said, dad, why,
why could you now I am dude. I had tears
in my eyes because this was, you know,
I'm like, fuck, I got another
heart, but I ain't gonna last long.
I'm going to be out of
here. So it was, you know,
it was fucking with me and the
doctor. Um, I answered that. Why?
I mean, why is he looked me in
eyeballs doing, she said, Mr Frichy,
we didn't want you to die. It's just
that simple. We didn't want you to die,
you know, that was what was available.
That was what was available.
It was a healthy heart and I
needed one badge, you know. Well,
that heart grow to match your body.
It already has really,
it is the proper size that it's,
it did.
Yes. And the doctor that
told me it was too small.
It was the one who told me that he had
grown through the proper sides. Wow.
Why does it grow? Because it recognized
it was in a bigger body. Uh, Joe, I,
you're on, that's on the physical. Uh, if
you look at it physically and probably a,
you know, with a rational
mind, that would probably be,
it realized that it had to
adapt to a large degree.
But I'm going to give him a little credit,
the car, because it's just me, man. So,
cause he came back too fast. I
mean, it was like a week later,
he said it's already decided that
she'd be a week later. A week later,
before I left the hospital,
he was telling me that it's
already should be Jesus.
And I said, see doc, I
told you I'm blessed man.
I thought that doesn't make any
sense. I know. What did he say?
Did the doctor say it doesn't make
any sense to a normal thing? Yeah,
I have no idea. I have no idea
if it's a normal thing or not,
but you know, I mean me, I'm getting
crazy. I'm going, wow. The other miracle,
thank God
I can say that question guy and I,
my answer was what did I,
I got back was was simple.
He said, if I gave you or an
18 year old Olympic athletes,
heart CT and you recovered was doing well,
then people are going to say that.
That's why you got an 18 year old Olympic
gold medal is hard and you're able to
recover and stuff because of this,
but if I take the old lady's heart,
there's two small and that not,
you're not supposed to be able to come
back and do these things with this heart,
then they're going to have to
give me a little credit. He said,
I have a habit of taking
the least of the least,
the lowest of the low and making something
out of it. And I said, you know what?
Let me shit the fuck up. You're absolutely
right. It wouldn't be that impressive,
right? It wouldn't be a miracle if I
eat all foods. It's wonderful heart.
But because I'm God,
I'm going to take this heart and give it
to you and you're going to still do all
those things. So shared up
CT, I said, okay, that's good.
Now when you exercise now and you just,
are you pushing or you just get into a
point where you just feel a little tired
and your back off.
Joe Rogan,
I can't help but push my say no.
That's what I'm asking is, you know,
I give, I gave her, I gave
everything I got. Yeah. I can't help.
It doesn't matter. Do you feel weird
when your heart starts beating heavy? Um,
or should I say her start her heart.
Her heart starts beating them pretty
fast and you know, I don't feel weird.
I feel like,
uh,
it's something I've done my whole life
and I'm just glad to be back, able to do,
you know, some of what I used to
do. It's just I feel good, you know,
I still talk to her though. Come on,
lady, I'm sure can get through this.
And now you feel it building up like
you feel like every month or so you get
stronger? Um, definitely.
Yeah, definitely.
I feel that the longer that it's in the
lungs, that, that the heart is in need,
the more it feels like, you
know, it's, that's where it
should be, you know, and my,
my body adapts.
And how long does a heart transplant
usually survive in a person?
Well, um, I think the longest,
at this point it's close to 40
years. 40 years. Wow. Yeah. Yeah.
I don't want 40 years.
I don't want to be a hundred man.
You don't know why not? Um, I want to, I,
you know, I never expected, like I
said, on June the eighth I'll be 60.
I never expected to make it to 40.
So you're really, really, yeah.
I never, I never expected that.
I expected to die young. So, um,
I'm way past what I thought I would
make it anyway. So it's a place.
Why did you think you you're going to
die that? Yeah. Oh Man. I never had,
I wanted to be a, I was, I was my,
and I want it to be the sky rocket
man. Brilliant. Like to shoot
this guy be a brilliant bursting then I
thought they would be the perfect ending.
Just go forward, go forward, go
forward, go forward and explode.
She can't dead motherfucker.
Yeah. But he was fine. He was,
he was something else when he was alive
and you happy with that, you know,
that's what you've thought. Yeah.
Yeah, definitely. Wow. Yeah.
Now you got to settle in for 41 years.
I don't even want to be photographed.
Why do you say that though?
Want to be alive right now and
every day is a blessing playhouse.
So why is it 40 years of blessing? It
would be a blessing, but I, man, you know,
I would be, um, I don't
want to be around where,
uh, um, I don't want to
be a burden on anybody.
And a hundred man, Yo, somebody
else got to take care of you.
Wipe your ass,
got wear diapers and shit.
And I don't know if I,
I w I wouldn't want to be around to
be a burden on somebody. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. I know what you mean. But right
now you're not a burden. I hope not. No.
I think my wife might disagree.
Wow. But you're moving around man.
I mean, like I said, if I didn't know, I
would have no idea. Well, I appreciate,
and even though I know you must've
lost some muscle, he's still,
if I just met you, I be like,
this is a Jack Dude. Yeah.
He's still got the size your arms, man.
There's still huge. I don't think so,
but prepared to what they used to be.
That's why. Yeah. Yeah. I guess I don't,
I don't see him as Hughes.
Yeah.
That's kind of stuff don't even
matter that much to me. Right.
I'm sure you have a new lease on life. Oh
yeah. Big Time. What matters to you know,
uh,
that the really important
things are crossing my family.
Uh, I'm in spreading. Um,
donor awareness is so,
so important because so many people
die just waiting to get her heart,
you know, on the list of 21, I
think 21 people a day pass away,
just waiting, trying to
get in. I was so fortunate,
so blessed to be able to get one that I
want to try to make sure that a lot of
people get one too. So whatever I
can do to try to raise awareness.
What is the problem? Like people putting
on that they'll donate their organs. Yes.
Well you can do it online now. Joan, you
try was right in California. You can,
I don't know about other states, but
in California you can do it all online,
you know,
and,
and through the DMV and get your
diet on your driver's license.
And I want to be a donor and I mean, you
can't take the stuff with you. No, wait,
no, he, people get paranoid
too. I've heard people say,
I'm worried about doing that because
what if they don't resuscitate me because
they need someone to get a
heart or a liver or something.
Like, I don't know, man.
I really don't think that's
what doctors are into now.